before creation itself there were six
singularities
forged into Infinity stones
everybody is Charlie surprise surprise
Avengers infinity war is actually going
to be censored some places around the
world that's right there are banned
scenes that are just being cut out
wholesale the Russo brothers were
reacting to it recently like what why
are you cutting out pieces of our movie
this is a pg-13 movie
so I'll explain what's going on what
parts of the film are gonna be censored
and who has to worry about it it only
happens a couple places around the world
where governments heavily censor stuff
so if you're watching this YouTube video
of me talking about it they probably
don't censor YouTube in your country so
you'll probably be fine so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
I'm doing an Infinity Gauntlet replica
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video the original cut of
the film is supposed to be a hundred and
fifty six minutes long so two hours and
36 minutes is what most of us are gonna
be watching in the movie theater it's
just a couple minutes longer than
Captain America Civil War so infinity
war is now officially the longest Marvel
film that they've ever released the way
that the Russos found out that some of
the film had been banned in their
country and it was gonna be cut down was
through a paper in Indonesia reporting
that the censorship board was releasing
a hundred and forty nine minute cut of
the film normally that wouldn't make
anybody prick their head up but if you
knew that the film was actually 156
minutes long you're like wait a minute
that's seven minutes of film that
they're cutting down that might not
sound like a lot but seven minutes is a
long freaking time considered that
there's a cut like an edit in every
scene every couple of seconds so that
means that they're cutting out a couple
scenes as well as parts of scenes across
the film it's not like they're just
taking one or two scenes out it's bits
and pieces like the black panther film
got censored in India because during
their fight Black Panther and kill
monger uttered the name of a Hindu deity
in they censor that they didn't want
people talking about that so usually
it's religious content sexual content or
extreme violence but it's a pg-13 movie
so naturally the Russos are like we're
shocked we can't imagine which seven
minutes that they would want to take out
of the film it's meant to be watched by
families it's being released by a
company that's owned by Disney the
family-friendly
company of all family-friendly companies
pretty easy cell and what they're
cutting down so like Doctor Strange
being tortured by ebony ma gonna take
that out for violence or at least cut it
way way down so that it doesn't linger
on all those spikes sticking in his face
there's really crazy things like in
China they cut down supernatural aspects
of films that deal with ghosts or a life
after death that is the soul gem so the
soul gem preserves life after death it
consumes them takes them down into the
soul world there's the idea that there's
going to be a big twist with the soul
gem in the movie that will involve
something like that even though it might
sound ridiculous like you go to see a
movie like this you understand that it's
sci-fi there's scenes with Scarlet Witch
and vision when they're a couple early
in the film before they go on the run
they've been living together as a couple
you can imagine what they've been doing
just sort of experimenting like you've
seen him making himself look like he's
more human he's fully functional he has
a vibranium body that he can turn into
anything he wants it to be not that
Marvel's gonna release a hardcore sexual
film but even the implication that a
human would have a relationship with a
robot like that like you can imagine
them censoring Guillermo del Toro shape
of water because the woman falls in love
with a fish man Sol if there's like a
scene with Scarlet Witch envisioned in
bed even if they're not doing anything
they'd still cut it out you have that
whole battle sequence where Scarlet
Witch and vision are fighting off
Proxima midnight in Corvus glaive before
Captain America and the Secret Avengers
come in there's a trailer shot where
Corvus glaive has his staff embedded in
visions forehead trying to take the gem
out just him screaming in agony just
like that dr. strange scene just becomes
a form of torture they cut stuff like
that way down you have the battle on
Titan which for the most part seems like
it's pretty safe I think everybody's
gonna be seeing the same version of that
but I think we're all expecting a
character to die on the planet that's
what they cut down Thanos just beating
someone to a bloody pulp like imagine
it's a version of John Carpenter's they
live roddy piper keith david fight this
just goes on and on and you're just like
screaming by the end of it they cut
stuff like that down like how long do
you linger on what you would call
graphic content that's where it gets hit
the hardest in countries like China
Indonesia is really where a lot of this
is being censored the only other thing
that's quicker to get banned is stuff
like in the Deadpool movie where he's
getting pegged the
definitely a sliding scale of WTF
concept but you have to imagine that the
more the film gets censored in other
countries the more awesome it sounds
like this was too awesome to be screened
we're too worried about what its gonna
do to people oh my god I have to see it
give it to me right now
first Deadpool movie didn't even make it
into China they're like don't even try
what would that poles message Bay to the
Chinese census that refused his film
Deadpool rated you you'll never see
this no I honestly it's easy for me to
wear that as a badge of honor like we
got banned in China I hate that I wish I
love China and I would love that the
people of China to see Deadpool it's too
bad because you know the reason they're
banning it is I don't think they get a
lot of the irony which ironic humor
isn't huge in China but they have such a
good sense of humor there's so many
hilarious action movies there that's
what this is it is a bummer that that
market won't get to see it so we
encourage everybody to make their way
over to America and check it out
starring in February you look like Shrek
took a on your neck you look like
the inside of other people's
this is the least confusing erection
I've ever had the drinks are not on
wait
use the money for sex not for friendship
promise me Tom
cameras on me now maximum alert Lennon
have some confetti for shoot miss maxim
of manipulates molecular allow her to
walk would you like another one moving
on same thing that shouldn't happen to
you
psychological around mother is really
hurt feelings if any of you do live in a
country that regularly censors movies
for specific types of content religious
sexual violent let me know usually what
ends up happening in those situations is
that the people that really want to see
the full cut of the film will just end
up pirating it or they try to find the
DVD six months later or they try to
watch some leaked on the Internet
usually just takes a little bit longer
but everybody does get to see that full
cut and there is a lot of deleted
material that didn't make the final
theatrical cut but that stuff like they
know says backstory stuff that they'll
put on the DVD
so don't worry there'll be all kinds of
crazy bonus content for the infinity war
in when we marathon both Avengers 3 and
Avengers for next year we can call it
the infinity watch it'll wind up being
some crazy movie that's longer than 5
hours I don't know how long Avengers 4
is going to be but I'm guessing it's
gonna be about the same length as
infinity war there is a whole bunch of
other infinity war stuff that's
happening this next week but leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post new Marvel my next
video will be the Walking Dead finale
that should post later tonight so look
out for that click here for more new
infinity war and click here to learn
about Thanos his backstory that they cut
from the film thank you so much for
watching everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]